both the hyperx quadcast and the blue
yeti have been out for
quite some time now but they are still
compared to each other
when it comes to getting the best usb
microphones so today we thought we'd
take a look at both
to really find out which is the best usb
mic in this price range but the first
thing you're going to notice about the
quadcast is obviously the bright red
that's pushing through the honeycomb
mesh that makes up the main shell
this isn't rgb if you want an rgb
microphone
then hyperx offer the quadcast s which
does let you change the color but for
now it's simply red
did i just reference a 80s
manchester brit pop band
now this mesh isn't just for the game
aesthetic although that's probably
a big selling point but it actually
doubles as a pretty
basic but very functional pop filter so
as long as you're not
directly breathing into this thing then
all of your
popping peas should sound perfectly
passable without
any aftermarket pop filter add-ons the
same red and black look covers the rest
of the microphone with its shock mount
elastics as well as the rubber top and
bottom and sturdy black shell it also
comes with a 9 foot usb cable which may
seem like a little overkill but there's
nothing worse than
short tight cables getting tangled and
limiting your mobility and flexibility
when it comes to your gaming or
streaming setup
this mic is also very light and has a
much
smaller profile than a lot of other mics
out there which is a big advantage for
me because i've been using it on my own
personal streams
and i would recommend it for other
streamers because it's not gonna be
covering that beautiful little face of
yours give the fans what they want you
know you don't want a big bulky
microphone
taking up the goods now the microphone
can be mounted on the handy little stand
that it comes mounted to
straight out of the box but it also has
a little adapter for if you want like me
to have it mounted on a boom arm but i
think my favorite feature of the
microphone is its mute functionality
this little
rubber top actually doubles as the mute
button and it's very obvious
when it's on and when it's off and what
was quite surprising is
you're tapping directly on the
microphone
but there's actual there's actually no
audible popping or banging when you're
making contact
it's nice and easy it's super functional
it's very readable to the user when your
mic is off as well as if you're
streaming to your chat
to inform them that your mic is off not
only do you know
that no one can hear you but they do as
well i stream a fair bit in my free time
and i am constantly forgetting to unmute
my microphone after coming back from the
bathroom or getting some more what have
you and then having my chat bully me
because i am 10 seconds into an escape
from tarkov raid and no one can hear my
voice
but now that i've got this crimson
beacon sat in front of me
since i've been using it for my streams
i've not forgotten
to meet my microphone once it seems like
such a small thing but it was like it's
a really nice quality of life thing if
you're going to be
using this for streaming and while this
microphone is mostly marketed towards
streamers it does come with four
different audio profiles
that can make it useful for interviews
podcasts
vocals etc etc the first being cardioid
that's going to capture basically
everything
here and that's going to probably be the
setting that 90
of people are going to use and it's the
the real default setting for
streaming discord voice overs that's
for when you just want to capture what's
in front of the microphone which is
usually your voice the next is
omnidirectional meaning that
everything around the microphone is
going to be captured and that's going to
probably be used for things like
if you're recording a podcast with a
group of people and you're only using
one microphone that means that everyone
can sit around this one thing
and all be heard the next setting is
bidirectional which means everything in
front and everything behind the
microphone is being recorded
that'll be for your one-to-one podcasts
interviews
and finally the stereo setting which
lets you split the audio between left
channel
and right channel so you can sort of
make
one ear have more of a treat than the
other which
i suppose you could use for vocals i
know some singers will
use it in stereo mode and if you're
someone that
likes to make asmr content
i don't know i've not really used it but
if you might have a use for it
comments down below those captures of
your beautiful voice can be adjusted
with the gain knob at the bottom of the
mic
and the quadcast really does have a
great range of gain all the way
from up close to really far away
it's echoey in here it's really hot but
the readings on the bottom of the
microphone really don't do a lot to tell
you where you're at the range of gain
actually goes way beyond the small dots
at the bottom so it may take some
tweaking to figure out what works for
you
here while i'm chatting you can hear me
click clacking away at my keyboard
that's using cherry mx brown switches so
you can sort of get
an indication as to how audible the
keystrokes are
the main rub is that if you use a
mechanical keyboard your microphone's
probably going to be picking it up but
if you're using discord or obs to stream
there's features in that software
that'll allow you to set a noise gate
and sort of limit that background noise
it isn't nearly as bad as some of the
microphones that i've heard
it does have the advantage that it's on
a boom arm if you have it on the desk
it is a lot worse and the stand kind of
vibrates along with it and you'll you'll
hear
the desk impacts as well as the
keystrokes but
it is manageable if you sort of tweak
the software but
the microphone as it is you are going to
be picking up some of that clicky clacky
noise if you're
gaming and using this at the same time
but all in all this is really a
fantastic microphone
as you've heard it has really great
clean audio that will let the crispiness
of your natural voice come through but
if you're looking to use this for gaming
or streaming then i have to recommend
that you get some kind of mic arm to
mount this thing because when i use the
stand that it came with it picked up
much more in the weight of keyboard
strokes and desk growl
now as you can see the blue yeti is a
much chunkier lad
than the quadcast it's bigger and
heavier and for me
doesn't sit well on my mic arm it
doesn't look quite right it almost feels
like i'm being bullied by this thing
it's it's very much
in my face and i've tried it in when i'm
streaming and it's really
sort of in your peripheral vision i
don't
i don't like it mounted on the arm but
it's the lesser of two evils when you
relate it to its
massive desk stand also you're left with
these open
ugly screw holes on either side of the
microphone if you're opting not to use
the stand that comes with it which if
you're looking for a gaming or streaming
mic
again i can't recommend using because
like the mic itself
the base stand be thick that's not to
say it's not an aesthetically pleasing
mic i've got the black one here and i
know it comes
in plenty of other colors and a lot of
people just aren't gonna like the red
black or
sort of illuminated look and that's
completely fine but
it is a good looking mic that i don't
want to see
it feels like i'm doing a co-stream and
there's a second person there
that's just just an obelisk that i'm
speaking into
as you can see though without the
additional pop filter or mount that the
quadcast has all the buttons and knobs
are a tad more accessible on the blue
yeti
your pattern switch the mute button that
flashes red when you're silenced
the microphones gain and it does
actually have a volume control knob to
adjust the headphone output
if you're monitoring your audio
something that the quadcast
doesn't feature after using the blue
yeti for a little while i realized how
much i was taking the very simple
shock mount and pop filter from the
quadcast for granted
now i've noticed as well that your
plosives and popping sounds
are a lot more noticeable with the yeti
to the point where i think
the aftermarket pop filter is
almost mandatory if you want to get the
most out of this thing i will say though
from when i was making videos
oh i started maybe seven years ago i
used another yeti product called the
snowball
and i looked online as to pop filter
solutions and somebody recommended
putting a sock over it as a makeshift
pop filter so
[Music]
so perhaps my precious pedial clothing
option can be
of some help when it comes to the pops
i mean it helps a little bit but you're
not going to be booting up your twitch
stream
with a bloody hiking sock on it the
point i'm trying to make is the
you need a pop filter for this thing
when you
take the aftermarket pop filter when you
factor in a shock mount things that come
on this
by default basic ones that they are they
become the exact same price really
it's an extra 10 bucks for a pop filter
maybe 10 to 20 for an aftermarket shock
mount whereas the quadcast is just like
it's got that coming out of the box but
it's definitely something you're going
to have to bear in mind
and prepare for if you're going for the
yeti but other than that it has a lot of
the same features
and the same polar patterns that the
quadcast has
four in total once again you can hear me
on cardioid the mode you're going to be
using most the one
for streamers voiceovers shouting at
your warzone teammates doing
sick gameplay breakdowns and trailer
reactions etc etc
bi-directional your one-to-one podcasts
interviews capturing either side
omnidirectional for your group podcast
using a single mic or your
quarterly business meetings and once
more the stereo setting
to allow you to stimulate each ear
separately and just as a treat you can
have me
at minimal gain and maximum gain
that's so loud i can see it peaking and
once more chatting away
using my keyboard they're about the same
distance away same keyboard
and the keystrokes are very audible
now when it comes to the audio profile i
suppose you can decide which
sounds best to your ears personally i
find this
a little warmer a little bassier but
they are extremely close
it's if it was a blind hearing test i
think i would struggle to really tell
the difference
but it is a really great microphone and
there is a good reason why a lot of
streamers
content creators and otherwise gravitate
to blue and their range of mics
when it comes to streaming making videos
and everything in between the blue range
really holds a special place in my heart
i'll admit that right now because like i
said before when i was
when i was a wee lad and i was making
videos in my bedroom
which i'm i'm now realizing i'm doing
now it was a different time
and different reasons but now we're in
2021 and we have two mics to choose from
which would be my pick as you can see
now that i've switched back to the
quadcast it is the one i prefer out of
both of these devices
don't get me wrong they are both really
great bits of kit but personally for the
smaller form factor the fact that it
comes
out of the box a little stronger with
its pop filter and shock mount
and personally i just prefer the lighter
crisper cleaner sound
of my voice that i get with the quadcast
aesthetically maybe i am just a cliche
gamer that wants all of my stuff to have
lights on
i'm not gonna deny that but i really do
dig the way it looks and the muting
is functionality that i get a whole lot
of use out of on my streams
again very simple but i'm a simple man
i like simple things and i love this the
blue yeti is a great mic
but i don't really like it for my
personal use i really
didn't dig it on the mic arm and when it
was on its stand it was just too big
and bulky to really fit anywhere
comfortably
and combined with the fact that you'd
ideally want to get a shock mount
and definitely a pop filter combined
with that they're basically the same
price
so you might as well just get something
ready out of the box that isn't going to
take up your entire fate
that smells new tech smell that isn't
going to take up
your entire face when you're streaming
so for that all of those reasons
it is narrow but it is narrowly beaten
by the quadcast
the yeti might be more comfortable in a
static recording studio
or in a home office but
for streaming for shouting at your
teammates in warzone
this little red menace i think is the
one for me
if either of these devices pique your
interest little audio joke for you there
then you can use the affiliate links in
the description down below to pick one
up for yourself
if you've used either of them let me
know your thoughts of them in the
comments section down below
make sure to subscribe like the video if
you did and i will see you in the next
one
[Music]
you